all right so
then so um then let's start um welcome
everybody and uh thank you for coming uh
my name is Arif um I'm working as a
consultant and developer For Thought
Works um but the last about 18 months um
I've been
working uh with these uh nice guys from
outo Scout um and this uh high
performance solution to microservice UI
composition that we're going to present
to you today um was developed during
that time um in a joint team of thought
workers and Autos
sces hello guys um my name is Alexia I'm
working as software developer at
autoscout 24 who who who um before we go
into topic of uh UI composition I'd like
to give you uh some background about uh
our company uh our motivation why we are
doing it and uh some context uh in which
we developed our solution uh uh to UI
composition um in Norway Autos Scout
probably not that known uh does anybody
Knows Autos Scout from here oh okay
couple of you so uh for everybody else
Autos Scout is uh u a Marketplace for
new cars and used cars and motorbikes
and stuff like that uh we are present in
17 countries in some countries we have
full presence like full feature at
Marketplace where we are having
contracts with our dealers and stuff
like that and in other countries uh we
have just translate translated version
of our uh search funnel um on our
platform we have about uh 24 2.4
millions of cars and uh
motorcycles and our platforms serves
about 3 billion uh page Impressions yeah
not hits but real P page Impressions per
month
um exactly um about one and a half years
ago we started a project uh that we call
Tatsu yeah just because every big
project have to have a
name um Tatu means Dragon you see that
uh logo uh on the background
um and uh it's a dragon because project
is more more less uh Rite uh of all of
complete platform uh of Autos Scout so
we uh compare it uh in our minds with uh
dangerous but quite powerful Dragon yeah
um in this in this project we doing five
uh things at the same time first of all
uh we are breaking old and TR monolitic
system into a bunch of self-contained
microservices uh we call them vertical
slices because yeah uh they having uh
everything uh they need inside of them
uh from database to UI and that's
actually why we are talking about UI
composition uh today uh we're also
moving from selfhosted data center in
the cloud well not in nro but in
AWS and um because it's more or less uh
building all the stuff from scratch on
on a Green Field uh I wouldn't call it
migration uh we just uh selected uh not
do net platform but Linux and jvm
platform to uh build it from the
beginning um just because uh it's not
enough uh for us we're also uh doing
some internal uh changes some changes in
our internal structure so um we changing
structure from uh having uh separate
operations department and uh uh
development teams to full feature teams
uh where operations people are members
of uh every team and uh teams having
knowledge uh to build uh to build and
run uh their stuff uh on you build it
uran approach that means uh teams
responsible to build stuff to test stuff
uh to deploy stuff and uh if something
breaks in the 4:00 in the night well to
fix stuff
uh yeah and uh just because otherwise it
will be too boring for us uh it's also
uh so-called shiny new card so our
platform is uh couple of years actually
more than 10 10 years old and over last
years uh there are some features which
were built at some point of time but are
not uh either not used uh by uh majority
of our customers or not used at all so
we we are
thinking what features do we really need
and cutting everything uh else out and
Yeah that's what uh shiny new cut uh
means
um this whole project obviously is a
huge for so why we are doing it uh one
of my main reasons uh for that stuff uh
is to reduce time to Market so we can uh
respond to needs of of our users more
quickly um for this uh it's really
important that uh we can uh release new
features uh very quickly uh also having
possibility to test AB uh doing AB
testing of some features uh and get uh
early user feedback so the idea of uh
that is to uh having possibility to
release uh stuff within minutes uh not
not days and not not even hours
um and uh we believe uh to do that uh
our teams should be enabled uh to be in
to to be able to innovate
independently um we believe uh that uh
key um to achieve this uh autonomous
team um that means they should be able
to work independently on their
services therefore we believe uh that um
it's crucial to avoid any form of uh any
tight C coupling as much as possible so
if team wants to improve uh their staff
but uh they have to wait for other teams
until uh they will be able to release uh
their services or their features uh it's
not real team autonomy so um in fact we
value uh Team autonomy that much uh that
we also accept certain trade-offs uh
like
in some cases we would rather copy code
around than introduce a shared Library
uh which will be used by multiple
Services um at the same time we don't
want to compromise uh page speed
um does anybody of you knows what uh
page speed insights
is no oh just couple of you so uh P
speed insights is a tool uh built by
Google that analyzes the structure of uh
of a page in terms of how fast page uh
could be rendered particular on mobile
browsers and uh score of uh page speed
goes up to 100 and good score is
considered starting from uh
85 we also strive for uh low
latency obvious uh that pages should be
rendered uh in s fast that means uh that
that we uh heavily rely on uh different
cach layers and uh that our Pages
shouldn't have any blocking
content in content of context of
microservices it's actually a bit tricky
to achieve uh both High page speed and
uh Team
autonomy all right uh thanks Alex so
um now in order to explain why it is
actually so hard to combine a page
performance with um good team autonomy
I'm now going to present to you two
different ways how to generally um
approach um this problem and um the
first of the two um ways is the API
Gateway pattern um does anybody of you
know the API Gateway
pattern all right so
um so let's take the um autoscout um
24.com page as an example here uh
actually the German page is much more
complex um but I think this uh uh page
here serves as a good simple example so
um you can see that um yeah it consists
of a main content and then there's a um
header and a footer I mean that's not a
very surprising structure of a web page
um so if we approach this now with a API
gate
pattern um then this could look like
this so
um here uh you see that in the back end
um the monolit is already broken down
into several independent services such
as the homepage service here or the
header and footer
service and now um for example this red
UI component here um could could
represent um this main part of the
homepage uh which is content which comes
from um uh yeah or which presents
content which comes from the homepage
service whereas you could imagine there
or orange part here as the footer um
which presents some content which comes
from the header and footer
service um so now uh you see in the back
end it's broken down into Services
different or independent services but in
the front
end um you see that it's still one big
um web application uh which takes care
of the whole web
UI and now in order to avoid that just
um when performing a s single action the
web application has to start several
requests to um several different backend
Services it's generally a good idea to
um introduce such an API Gateway here
here in between uh which Aggregates
requests and thereby um dramatically
reduces the number of requests um that
is required for a single action um which
is particularly important um when you
view the page on a uh mobile
device so um this is generally um the
idea or one of the main ideas of the API
Gateway pattern
um so it's actually great for page
performance um because um you have this
request aggregation and also this single
web application it's fairly easy to
optimize for good uh page loading times
because you have all in one application
you can optimize it all together and
thereby get um good page
performance um however there are quite
some drawbacks to this API Gateway
pattern and um the main drawback here
for
us is that there are or that truly
independent feature releases are not
possible at least not if um those
feature releases include something being
changed in the back end and in the front
end so um let's say something
uh needs to just something in the footer
needs to be changed so there is some
change in the um header and footer
service and um some visually needs to be
changed in the web UI then in the worst
case three teams have to be coordinated
to just make this single change um the
web application team or the team that
takes care of this web application um
the team that takes care of the API
Gateway and the team that is responsible
for the header and footer service um so
this is no re no truly independent um
feature release and that is because the
um yeah we basically just went half way
here of breaking down the monolit
because we only broke it down in the
back end but we still have kind of a UI
monolit so um to sum it up this approach
um is good for page performance um but
it's rather bad for team autonomy and
now because we actually do this whole
effort of rewriting the auto um Scout uh
side um to get more team autonomy and
get faster
um or faster in releasing new features
um this drawback really um rended this
uh AP Gateway pattern um no option for
us at least not for the web um
page so um instead we went um for
another pattern and this is now the
second pattern um I'm presenting which
is the uh UI composition
pattern so um the same thing now with
this pattern would look like that
so um again imagine the uh Autos Scout
page and now in this example here the
homepage service um would contain the
backend Logic for the for the homepage
service but would as well deliver the
actual HTML JavaScript and um
stylesheets um and similarly the and
footer service would contain the backend
logic and would also deliver um this
yeah the HTML the JavaScript and the CSS
which is required for that footer piece
of the um autoscout
page um
and because uh and yeah that's the
reason why we call those uh Services
vertical slices Alexa already mentioned
it uh because um with this
pattern basically each service contains
a front end part a back end part and
everything in between so there is no
classical layered architecture
anymore um and uh This Way each team can
basically change their backend and their
UI at the same time pretty much
independently of course just as long as
it doesn't affect other parts of the
page but if it doesn't they can really
completely independently release their
change and do not have to coordinate
with anybody else so um this UI
composition pattern approach is really
great for team
autonomy however there are quite a few
challenges that come with that
approach so um first of all um all
those pieces of the page that come from
different um backend services or
different Services um have to be um
combined into one single HTML page in
the end because that's uh what is
delivered to the
user
um furthermore um we must enable each
service to deliver not only the HTML but
also um uh the style sheets and the
JavaScript at the same
time then the page structure must not
break or the the final page structure
must not break um the page performance
and that is actually already getting
tricky because any single service that
is part or that that delivers some
content which is displayed on the page
in the end could introduce some random
blocking content and thereby basically
um pull down the page performance um of
the whole
page and um the same goes for the
request latency um because of course the
latency is determined by the slowest of
all services that are involved um so
generally you could say um whereas team
autonomy is really good with that
approach um achieving good page
performance is a bit tricky
here um and then finally um
also um independent testing of those UI
components um and also testing them with
integration is a CH is a challenge with
that
approach now um in order to illustrate
you how much of a challenge um such a
high performance UI composition is I'm
going to quickly tell you the story um
of our first um well not particular
successful approach um to solve this
problem um and that approach was uh
based on varnish and
ESI um who of you knows what varnish
is Right quite a few so um uh varnish is
um an HTTP proxy cache um you can also
call it an HTTP
accelerator um and who of you knows what
ESI is
okay not that many so um ESI means Edge
side
includes and Es and ESI teac is
basically an HDML element uh which can
then be replaced with some content which
could come from another
service um so um let's see how this uh
looked in our particular environment
which was uh or is AWS based um so
you see here there is an instance of
this um varnish uh proxy cache and there
is an elastic L balancer elb in front of
varnish and then we have those um
Upstream Services how they are called in
this um ter terminology and there is a
um uh elb in front of each of those
Services now if um a request from a
browser hits uh or is now requesting the
homepage then this would hit um the
varnish varnish would route this to the
homepage service the homepage service
would
um deliver an HTML page which consist
con um contains some ESI text for in for
instance an ESI Tech um saying uh here
comes the footer and um then varnish
would go back to the footer service
retrieve the content of the footer
service replace this in here and
delivers this back to the
client so um let's have a look how this
uh looks in
code so um this yeah would be a really
dumped down example of how um the
content could look like um from the
homepage service so you see this is a um
normal HTML page um with HTML Texs
around it and then you see up here the
um head section with already minified uh
style sheets and down here um you
see uh also um JavaScript which is
already minified and here you see there
is the ESI tag which simply says ESI
include and then you see here the source
um routes to the um German
header so now um this gets replaced um
by varnish and then you see this is the
content which is delivered by the um
footer service
um uh no it was the header actually so
this the header um and you see now there
is the stylesheet of the header the
actual content of the header and the
JavaScript of the header
um now the problem of this page
structure structure as this is that that
um the page speed would be really bad or
is really bad because um we have now
random blocking um styles sheet links
and JavaScript um scattered all over the
place or all over the um page so uh yeah
from the page speed inside score would
be would be really
bad okay so then we thought how can we
um improve this um and an idea that we
had was to split up this include into or
this this um yeah getting the content
from the uh different Services into
multiple ESI includes so basically
include um the content at three places
first here uh one include for
the uh
Styles and then and that is already in
the head section here and one include
for the actual content and then another
include for um the
JavaScript so um
in this case if this now gets replaced
um we have a good structure so the um
page speed would be much better that way
um however we now have another problem
um and that is really um tricky as well
so and that is that is asset version
inconsistency or possible version
inconsistency so imagine now we would um
release a new version of the uh
header and um this new version of the
header would come with a new some new
HTML content and also some uh new
stylesheets now of course because we
want to provide good page performance
we're caching everything right and
especially varnish is a cache so uh
we're actually caching um those
responses from the um Upstream services
so now um those different things here
could have different different times to
live or basically the the cash could be
invalidated at different times so that
means it could happen that we already
get the new content the new HTML content
but the cach is not invalidated yet um
for the sty sheet so we still get the
old Star sheet and therefore we have
inconsistencies here so and um right
away we actually did not see with this
approach of um
separate uh ESI includes we did not see
a to solve this so this was a um a huge
problem here
um also um another thing is that um the
uh assets are not combined yet but
that's even a minor uh issue in um
comparison to the version in consistency
because this may not be such so much of
an issue if you only release once a
month or whatever but uh as we um
release several times per day um yeah
this situation is much more likely to
come up
um yeah so basically what was the
situation at that point we had the our
team had the job to build a solution for
um the U UI composition of the new Alo
scul
page and with the first attempt uh with
varnish and ESI we had either a bad page
performance because of a bad page
structure and then um attempts to
optimize the page structure led into an
increased complexity um regarding the
asset handling
um furthermore this approach with having
multiple ESI includes um puts a high
burden on the teams actually providing
this content um because they have to
provide three different end points for
the for the different things um and uh
also combining assets with ESI is uh
possible but also adds more complexity
and then above all those issues um we
had a specific um issue um an issue
specific to our environment there um
because we are using AWS elastic load
balancers um so an elastic load balancer
um actually consists of multiple IP
addresses because of the multiple
availability
zones but now varnish actually
says as a Upstream service I want one IP
address otherwise I'm not going to start
to work so
that was basically and the killer um
issue that we could not go down that way
so um yeah we um kind of uh had a bad
week uh so um yeah we had a lot of
problems um but at least we knew by now
um what were the requirements for a
better solution so um we knew that um
the solution that we needed to provide
um uh
in this solution it would need to be
possible for the um Upstream services to
provide um the links to the assets and
so on as part of the HTML itself so that
we do not have those version
inconsistencies
um and at the same time in order to get
a good page performance this means that
we need a solution with some post
processing um furthermore we wanted to
have some support for combined assets to
um get a better page performance and
also um inlining uh CSS and JavaScript
would be nice um and finally um uh it
would be nice to have uh support for
shared cach between instances um because
we're using immutable servers and
therefore um yeah it would be really
nice not to kill the cache with every
release right um yeah so that were the
requirements that we came out of of this
first uh failed um attempt to solve the
problem and um now Alexa is going to
tell you uh what solution we then came
up with yeah um so we finally found uh
right solution that uh satisfied all our
requirements and um at the end uh our
solution uh consist of three main parts
so it's uh at first it's in genix if SSI
module to resolve include so it's
basically uh SSI module is very similar
uh to what isi uh functionality in
varnish uh is doing uh second part of it
is a page speed module for in jins which
is developed by Google and uh which is
doing post processing um post
optimization for composite pages and uh
third
uh uh third part part is uh AWS uh
elastic cach which is nothing more than
M casd um it was basically externalized
uh cash uh so uh our services uh were
completely
stateless and uh in Azure world uh there
will be Windows Azure caching something
like that uh we checked exactly like M
casd uh
yeah um so let's check uh what how
request flow Works uh so when request is
coming from browser uh toins uhin uh
results from configuration that uh for
this path is some Service uh responsible
and sends request to a
service um service returns uh page with
uh SSI
includes
which gets passed and uh in Jinx uh and
SSI module uh resolves all uh SSI
fragments uh on the page and loads them
from uh different Upstream
Services um afterwards p is given to uh
Eng Jin's page speed module which is
doing
postprocessing uh in particular it
prefetches all uh assets or Styles all
javascripts um combines uh them and uh
generates uh single link out of it
places uh JavaScript just below the page
and style all styles in the header and
uh yeah um and in addition to that we
have uh two level cach uh but uh we'll
talk uh about this uh in a
minute and afterwards postprocessed page
uh sent back to uh to browser and
uh as we found at the end it worked much
much uh better than our first attempt um
with
varnish all right so um now before
showing again how this all looks in code
um I just want to explain that we
conceptually distinguish between um what
we call a page and what we call a
fragment so um pages are generally
publicly accessible um via URL um
whereas a fragment really is just a part
of a page so um Pages get call get
called um from the client so the browser
um whereas fragments really just get
called from engine access SSI module in
this case um a page can include
fragments obviously um but also
fragments can include fragments so we
can Nest fragments but of course a
fragment cannot include a
page then a page could be cachable
however there could be various reasons
why a page um could not be uh cached
such as cookies or so um a fragment on
the other hand should really be cachable
so the idea is that a fragment is a
rather static thing a static small thing
that can be cached easily um
and then finally Pages Define contracts
for fragments and fragments have the job
to adhere to those contracts so they
have to behave well as part of the page
for instance not consuming more space on
the page um than they're allowed
to so um now let's have a look again on
a simple HTML page here coming um from
the homepage service again you see now
now um this looks very similar as in the
uh ESI approach um so again you see here
the minified and actually already
combined um stylesheets and down here
the JavaScript um and here this is now
the SSI
include um in contrast to esit Texs um
SSI includes are basically just HTML
comments um which then say hash include
virtual and then again you see there's
the um yeah the path to the German
header in this case so this gets then
replaced um by engine AIS SSI
module and again you see here that um
this is the cont that that comes back
from the header service here and um you
already see the content that it gets
delivered by the header service um has a
nice normal structure structure it has a
head section with the sty sheets in
there then the actual content and then
as you would do it normally at the end
there is the script section so um from
the perspective of the team that is
delivering that content um that fragment
or the content of this fragment is
relatively easy to um to test also to to
display and isolation and so on of
course now we have the same issue as
before the page per performance of this
page as it is would be really bad so
therefore now um the engine x uh page
speed module or mod page speed comes
into play and um this mod page speed
provides um several filters and one of
those filters is combined heads and
basically those filters are
post-processing steps and um so now
going back here you see there is a head
section here and the content that has
been delivered by the header service and
there is a head section here and then
the combined heads filter would do um
what you would assume that it does um
and thereby basically pulling up this um
Star sheet link up here into the head
section um so this already improves um
the page speed but it's not that great
yet um and then there's the next filter
uh that we apply which is uh combined
CSS and JavaScript and this filter now
really combines uh all those Styles
sheet links up here um and also it
combines all the JavaScript down here so
now really
um uh we have a really good um page
structure with a good page speed and in
here the only thing is that is left is
the actual content or left untouched is
the actual content that um came from the
header
service so actually with those more or
less with those two filters um there are
many more filters of mod page speed um
we were able to get a really good um
page speed score so of this um uh small
page that we developed um that uses this
um UI composition we were able to get a
score of 97 for desktop and even 96 for
mobile so um those are actually really
great numbers um although I have to warn
you if you go to that page or the Autos
scope page right now it will actually
show lower numbers because we have
ongoing this discussions um whether we
want to load the font uh synchronously
or asynchronously and because right now
the decision was to load it
synchronously the page speed is rather
bad um which is an example of how one uh
page um or one fragment being able to
pull down the whole um the whole page
speed of the whole page but generally um
apart from that the the page speed um
that can be achieved is really
great so uh yeah now Alexa is going to
tell you something about caching yeah
right uh let's talk about caching uh
small uh recap of how the whole stuff is
working uh so request is going into
engin SSI module PES load fragments
resolved uh uh Pages passed by uh page
speed module and then all assets uh are
prefetched and um let's check uh how um
one of our two uh cach levels uh and why
um is working so first of all uh we have
a um so-called proxy cache which is
basic uh sits at the lowest level uh of
uh request processing Pipeline and it
caches actually responses from uh
Upstream services this uh adds U as
additional level of resilience that
means if uh some service will go down
yeah uh we will be able to get content
out of cash well better stale content
than no content content at all
right um second
uh cash headers from uh Upstream
services are always respected so uh we
think that teams know how to cach how
their stuff should be cached so uh we
are not forcing uh them to do anything
uh
here
um we also support cash key uh
modifications uh via um very here I will
talk about this in one of the next
slides and uh the whole stuff is
externalized in aw elastic uh AWS
elastic uh cache which is nothing less
uh than
mcash uh mcash
um
um could not be attached directly to
engins uhin can read out of it but not
right uh right into it so uh we enabled
it by using Jin's uh cach module as cash
model um
yeah uh second level of cash is uh cach
for uh postprocessing uh post-processed
uh and optimized P pages and
assets that means that all generated
assets which are already combined and
minified and stuff like that are stored
there again it's same elastic cach uh
which basically enables us to uh to
throw away servers so our uh servers are
completely
stateless um
yeah
um it also uh allows us to uh do a
rolling update without uh having any c
synchronization and uh the cool thing
about it we never have uh called Cash
And since cash uh is completely
externalized uh this solution is scaling
uh horizontally to almost unlimited
number of uh instances serving all
requests well of course limitation of
mkd uh still applies but yeah it also uh
can be scaled horizontally pretty
good so um how caching of assets working
uh working here uh all our uh assets
pictures and uh Styles and and
javascripts are fingerprinted that means
that uh during compilation they uh there
are hashes generated out of content of
uh files and hashes added to file name
that means if you do some modification
to uh those files you will always always
always get a new file name that means
every single version is uni has unique
file name that means uh we can cash it
for like forever
yeah well forever probably not good idea
because sometimes your cash will be
filled and so we say let's cash it for
one year and uh this thing is controlled
by uh our microservices serving assets
and uh our UI composition layer is just
uh respecting all cash heers coming out
of uh Upstream
services oh yeah um second level of cash
uh which is basically sitting on on
uh near page uh page speed uh modu is uh
caching all combined assets um when AR
was talking about processing page uh he
said that uh all assets are prefetched
combined and there is one single link
generated out of it where all assets are
just put together and uh just to not
burn uh CPU every time when yeah because
processing cost uh cost CPU just to not
burn CPU every time uh page is served we
are caching calculated versions of uh
our
assets okay let's check uh how cach of
documents uh is working so it's uh more
or less the
same um cash of uh proxy module uh still
respects all um cash uh headers coming
out of uh Upstream Services the only
difference is that at this point you
have only one level of cash because yeah
uh there is nothing to combine so Pages
basically get SED uh get SED from
services and it's not getting minified
or combined or something like
that um there is possibility uh to
control
uh cash Behavior by uh adding a
verer why we do need this um on the
front of from outside our website is
visible on uh 17 different domains
right and uh having uh all 17 different
domains for all services Upstream
Services which are serving content
is quite overhead yeah so we decided to
uh keep one single domain uh for uh
Upstream
Services uh but we still need to catch
somehow uh different version of content
because of different languages right and
um uh our proxy module is transforming
uh what is doing is transforming cookie
where user stores uh his language
settings into a uh you see here here had
a ex cookie
culture
taking value out of uh uh culture
cookie and sending this header to
underline services to
uh while retrieving fragments because
otherwise underlying Services cannot see
uh underlying Services certain fragments
cannot see original requests they are
so-called sub requests in engine so only
page request uh se's original uh
original request and fragments just
don't see it this way uh we enabling uh
we enabling uh services to say if you
have some content based on language uh
it's also possible to evaluate uh uh
Language by transer transforming cookie
into header uh variable and service can
say yeah my stuff should be cached based
on this cookie and then value of uh
based on this header and this uh value
of this header is uh added to kki
afterwards okay uh
testing uh when you're developing uh
your stuff of course uh it's good idea
to test it a releasing stuff untested is
doesn't work that well um but how toest
test uh your single Service uh which you
runs on your machine if uh everything
else served from I don't know from maybe
10 services or 20 different
Services let's check how it's working uh
it's already you should should already
know this Pages uh our International
homepage uh having uh free uh fragments
header footer and uh main area which
comes out of uh uh H page
service
and let's say uh we want to change and
test uh header locally so you have your
developer machine where you develop your
header uh and you want to check how it
fits into the page and plays uh uh if it
plays nicely together with other parts
of uh the page so we built a Docker
container which is
basically uh same chicksaw configured
same way with only difference uh that
caching is completely disabled
there all other parts of functionality
are absolutely the same and it's
possible uh to say to this doer
container please take my service from my
local machine while all other services
will be still taken uh out of the cloud
so this way in Jinx combines uh content
and delivered by your local service from
your local machine while everything else
is yeah get out of production
basically um when team started using
this solution they
uh sometimes had unexpected uh behavior
and uh sometimes were getting unexpected
uh page speed scores and uh long
rendering time
so uh when we started analyzing what's
going wrong we figured out that uh we
have some uh some errors which some
mistakes which are um happening quite
often so we uh build so-called uh best
practice
analyzer and uh it's nothing else than a
some script analyzing uh fragments and
uh HTML Pages for some anti patterns for
example defer a sync
if you say Yeah in fragment my
JavaScript should be loaded as different
think P speed will say no I will not do
anything with it because uh it cannot
predict uh in which order your stuff
should be loaded and
executed another way another thing is
Page
barrier um in
uh page speed mode there are so-called
page barriers it's in line script uh
inline
javascripts uh which are not loaded
externally but just yeah inlined in this
case order of execution is uh important
and uh page speed module cannot combine
assets across uh page border so that
means if you have some fragments above
page border and some fragments below
page border page speed module will
unfortunately not combine anything which
will uh affect your page uh P speed
score again another thing is Styles
outside of head or Styles sheets uh
references with different attributes and
couple of other things and uh we build
it as a script oops which can be run in
a development pipeline uh deployment
pipeline which means if something is
going going wrong here yeah your build
will just
break that's
it um of course the whole
stuff even if
uh it's working pretty well the whole
stuff is still work in progress right
and uh not all problems are solved and
we have couple of things uh which
are yet has to be solved have to be
solved and one of those things
is authentication what to do with Pages
uh which requires authentication and how
to serve content which should be
protected for particular uh
users another thing is native mobile
applications if it's possible somehow to
benefit uh from combining parts of
yourui in Native mobile application well
you canot solve everything at uh at
once all right um so let's come to the
conclusion
um so uh yeah what are the features of
the I composition solution that we built
um with this solution um which we call
jigsaw internally um teams are really in
full control of their services UI and do
not need to rely and coordinate on other
on others when changing it at least if
it doesn't affect others um so um we
have really autonomous teams um also
fragments have a simple structure with a
head some kind of body and script um
section or part so it's relatively easy
for services to provide and test their
content um page performance is not
compromised in any way uh on the
contrary um page performance can
actually be really high because of the
good post
optimization
um also um beyond that jigsaw serves as
a really effective uh cach layer uh with
multiple cach levels and um as Alexa
just showed you um with this jigsaw
Docker solution um uh fragments can be
tested in isolation and also in
integration with other Pages or
fragments um yeah and uh most important
thing of all it's life and it serves um
thousands of requests uh per second
flawlessly um it's live with a current
uh German autoscout um homepage and uh I
think the list page um and we're
actually really happy with the solution
um whereas we came from from a point
where we thought wow this is a really
hard problem um and um we had at a some
point in time uh we're wondering how
we're going to solve this and um now
we're really happy with the
solution let me show you one thing well
I
hope it will work
somehow great
here's a uh result page when
user whoops where is my mouse when user
uh searching for something well I drive
uh Audi A4 so I'm looking for Audi A4
usually when uh need to test some pag uh
Pages um so in this case Audi A4 uh
there are couple of thousands uh of
search results um well
connection uh here at the venue is not
that fast as uh expected but you see I
just reloaded page it's rendered almost
instantly and uh what's interesting in
this page which contains uh yeah some
results we have almost 30 fragments so
actually every item um showing here in
this list is a fragment so every item
which is yeah single uh car displayed on
the result page is a single uh is a is a
separate fragment yeah yeah and this
means that actually also every of those
items can be cached at those multiple
levels that we
shown yeah and
then I think uh that's it and um we're
happy to uh answer any questions that
you may have and thank you for your
attention oh
again too fast but anyway
okayed I have a question for so now
every team builds the CSS styles on it
own so how do you avoid that these
things flut yeah so
um so far we're just using um uh
JavaScript uh uh um packages and um sty
sheet namespaces for this um and we were
afraid at a point that this would not be
enough as isolation um so far it
actually um works fine so uh yeah we
Comm communicate well and actually it's
also part of this best practice analyzer
which checks that you use um name spaces
for your service and so far this is
actually enough um so we were um afraid
of this as well because the solution
provides no actual isolation um but yeah
so far we're haven't run haven't run
into any problems um yeah we had the
same the same fear in our mind about
this thing part of our uh of our company
uh culture is uh to give people uh a lot
of uh Freedom uh and if you're giving uh
good people a lot of freedom and I hope
all our guys are good uh guys uh you
figure out that people actually don't
misbehave so if you uh says guys please
do it like this and they actually doing
it like this uh of course uh nobody is
nobody stops guys developing homepage to
call their styles to put their Styles in
footer name space but well it will be
kind of stupid yeah and I mean it is
really um interesting because um this
page gets combined really late um
basically any service can mess up um the
entire page I mean we we check a lot of
things and this best practice analyzer
in the pip line but still um really
teams have to um rely on other teams not
um messing up with a page um but yeah
this gives a lot of um freedom and
Agility to the different teams and so
far it's working um very well I mean we
had certainly small incidents but um
yeah made um pretty good experiences
with this model so far yeah um do you
have any kind of rules in terms of for
example JavaScript libraries that you
don't end up with like three of J F and
angular and react and then if you want
to upgrade also how you handle that yeah
um yeah the point is uh that um user
experience uh well in the past it was
not that uh uh not the case but uh now
user experience is uh the most important
thing uh for us and uh rendering of uh
of whole uh page uh should be blazing
fast uh that means we are trying to
avoid using any uh heavyweight libraries
like jar so uh yeah if uh team needs
some functionality they're free free to
use uh some smaller libraries and uh
yeah we have just avoid using some huge
Frameworks like uh angular jqu or
whatever that could be the same thing
that different uh Services need like the
same Library you have different versions
have to thebr three times in there yeah
so so currently we um approach this the
following way um
we um import those libraries or some
libraries or also um as I mentioned
before um the font um as part of the
page so not as part of the fragment so
and then
um the fragments that get included on
that page assume
those uh libraries and um fonts to be
there so there's kind of they they rely
on this um we don't know whether this is
going to be the final solution to this
but this is currently how we approach
this um yeah and thereby yeah the page
um uh is responsible for providing um
those uh uh those libraries and the good
thing here is that the responsibility is
pretty clear so um the team that
maintains the page P or is responsible
for the page is responsible for the page
performance and thereby if any fragment
providing service messes up with a page
score um or needs um uh needs another
version of a library or so they have to
talk to each other um and the and the
team um taking care of the page is
actually um taking care that um
everything uh is all right with that
page
how did you come up with all those boss
processors how did you find it like I
just Google it oh here is put it there
uh yeah um pretty much there's a leap
there between the first attempt and then
you presented there and they're there I
was like wow okay yeah it's um yeah it's
a good question I mean um basically we
we were looking into varnish and SSI and
yeah we had all those problems and then
we basically um went into the weekend um
and then a colleague of Mine morit hyber
He's from thoughtworks as well um just
came back from the weekend and said well
I have an idea there is um uh this um
page speed module from Google and um it
can be used in engine x uh and what we
had ideas before to use engine X in
order to make varnish work with elbs to
put an uh engine X in between so we
already had engine X on the on the page
kind of and then he he um remembered
that there is this page speed module for
uh engine X and that it could actually
solve all our problems um but yeah so so
our mood really turned from oh wow we're
really frustrated to oh wow that's a
cool
solution
great uh
well um so this this is a server side
inclue Solutions any idea how you would
do things like this with single page
apps where you actually have to do all
of this on the client
that is a really good question
um to be honest we have not thought
about this at all because yeah this is
not how
the how the SC page currently works so I
guess for uh for now we don't have any
any uh pieces of functionality which
builds uh build uh as a single page
application uh probably it will not work
if uh we will try but uh for now we have
no answer for that yeah yeah you could
try to come up with a similar approach
like having some post processing on the
client side but yeah uh maybe you could
use the same approach and adapted to
that but yeah we haven't looked into
this at
all um think back aut deoy production
Yeah we actually have um a completely uh
continuous um integration and delivery
so um to be specific um right now uh
every um commit that is pushed um goes
uh automatically through through produ
to production um if it passes all tests
so some of the tests includ the P yeah
yeah yeah indeed that fails it be right
yeah at least if it fails dramatically
and then of course we have monitoring um
which checks the pay as well so of
course if uh if it's going from 95 to 94
of course it will be still deployed but
if if it's going from 95 to let's say 60
yeah build will be uh
broken mention that you you switch to to
Java have you been a net shop before Y
how did that work well uh let's have a
chart uh afterwards
what is the reason then why well you
usually it goes the other way around no
it's yeah I mean we we basically
switched um or well we have to say they
um because I was only involved in the
project at that point where it was
decided that um there would be the uh
the migration to um to Linux and um jbm
um uh so um we basically went at Autos
Scot from C being the main language to
scal being the main language because um
I think was agreement uh with the
developers that they didn't want to go
from C to Java uh not even Java 8 uh so
um yeah and then uh I think yeah I think
it has been um quite a challenge uh the
migration but um at least from my point
of view um developers are generally
quite happy with Scala I mean you have
to say so yeah um yeah but of course
it's uh it's a huge migration with lots
of um uh knowledge sharing and uh
knowledge build up um needed yeah it's
not it's not like uh uh C is a bad
language or something or net is a
totally miserable runtime no of course
not uh
unfortunately um now it's getting better
over uh last year or two um there was
lack of uh automation for Windows
platform so it was possible to automate
a lot of things but since
uh we thought about uh uh doing
completely automatic uh continuous uh
deployment right um
our our infrastructure is completely uh
coded yeah and checked in in
repositories so the zero manual interv
intervention in provisioning service
configuring services and and all that
stuff so basically uh changing we were
not changing to Scala as a as a Target
right uh we were changing to uh platform
which allows us uh to automate all the
stuff better uh than it was possible at
that moment uh with uh Windows platform
and
uh unfortunately now it's as I said
getting better and better at this point
of time uh it was not possible to run uh
net applications on Linux so yeah it was
more less obvious decision yeah I think
the main strategic decision was to move
to AWS and then um and then the decision
for Linux and jvm followed from
that yeah I know it's it's not that cool
to explain all that stuff at net
developer confidence right but
well so no question
anymore
[Music]
yeah why not know GS well well I
mean well I mean we're we're using npm
in the front end at all kinds of places
but um yeah we're doing server side
rendering with the play framework oh
server site
um uh yeah Frameworks um yeah I think
there was no um no specific decision
about this
um
yeah all
right one of your was the version of
JavaScript have you considered getting
rid of javascri completely of what
getting rid of JavaScript completely
like using react prob um no so far so
far not no okay all right um thank you
very much
um and have a good
[Applause]
evening